and finally new rule Democrats must
learn how to support a very important
part of their coalition other Democrats
I know everyone is excited about Connor
Lam winning in Pennsylvania this week
but watching his TV ad is why I worry
about how this party fights my opponent
wants you to believe the biggest issue
in this campaign is Nancy Pelosi it's
all a big lie I've already said on the
front page of the newspaper that I don't
support Nancy Pelosi okay so this was a
special election to replace a Republican
who was staunchly pro-life but got
caught pressuring his mistress to have
an abortion and the Democrats let it
become a referendum on Nancy Pelosi how
about this for an ad Democrats support
abortion soda Republicans when they need
one for their girlfriend
[Applause]
Nancy Pelosi was never a scary radical
and Democrats long ago made a horrible
mistake in deciding that when the
Republicans called her that they would
just duck their heads and go along what
Nancy Pelosi did was passed the stimulus
that averted a depression past the very
best version of a health care bill this
country has ever had passed Wall Street
Reform after the Great Recession and the
bill that saved the auto industry passed
the Fair Pay Act these are things to
brag about not distance yourself from
learn the lesson that's staring you in
the face every day in the person of
Donald Trump voters don't care about how
smart you are just don't be a [ __ ]
Hillary Clinton got 26% of the vote in
West Virginia Trump did better with
Hispanics after calling them rapists and
killers Trump once said to a crowd in
Iowa how stupid are the people of Iowa
and then one Iowa in a landslide as the
people cried it's about time somebody
leveled with us about how stupid we are
their attitude is insult me lie to me
just leave me Hillary had the right plan
for coal country get them off coal now
we've got to move away from coal and all
the other fossil fuels but I don't want
to move away from the people who did the
best they could to produce the energy
that we relied on everything about that
answer was right what she did what
Democrats always do the second there was
the slightest backlash she back pedaled
it was a misstatement because what I was
saying is that stop stop you already
lost it wasn't a misstatement it was the
truth and
she should have said you heard me Cole
is dead and it's about goddamn time it's
dirty it's killing the environment and
it's killing you instead of pretending
it's a great thing that a West Virginia
man can die in a hole looking for rocks
just like his daddy and his daddy before
that how about we're the party that's
gonna get you out of the hole what
happened to selling the American dream
of a better life for your kids but
Democrats are too political courage what
Velveeta is - cheese Republicans just
added 80 billion to a defense budget
that was already more than Russia's
China's and the next five countries
combined including Wakanda and the
Democrats went right along when they
should be saying this isn't defense
spending it's welfare for defense
contractors and the reason we never have
money for anything else but just like
the Democrats position on coal love it
had some for breakfast and guns
I love the Second Amendment - they're
afraid to make the counter argument
Republicans they're all claws and sharp
teeth and fangs when they fight the
Democrats their weapon of choice is
adaptive coloration
I'm a leaf don't eat me
vote for me I'm the same pattern as the
couch
so how about this Democrats let's create
a brand new issue out of thin air just
like the Republicans do and you can use
it to practice having balls and we'll
pick an issue that actually would help
you and that issue is this why the [ __ ]
do we need two Dakotas
are they really that different I don't
think so combine these two states with a
total population of 1.6 million get four
senators California with a total
population of have you seen the 405 get
two there are more people in California
named Dakota than there are in the
Dakotas